I did a movie
um
and Henry Winkler was on there and I had
made a comment about
not not being good enough or not fitting
in with them or something because there
was there were all these Tom Arnold was
there there were all these great actors
around and on and then I I don't know
how I got there and I just remember
Henry Winkler made me go home he goes in
the mirror that you look in every day
you're gonna write in lipstick and and
now I've forgotten exactly what it was
but it was something like I am good
enough
something to that degree and so he told
me to do that and so I went home and did
that and I always thought of him you
know he is
such a mess still texts me Michael how
are you I hope you and your brother are
great how's the dog I love you
Shannon I want you to write in lipstick
I am good enough
Shannon
he is the best and by the way I've been
doing hypnotherapy in there it's amazing
how when you rewire your brain and you
and you bring confidence and repetitive
confirmation like what's the word uh
affirmations affirmations yeah to you
then you you change the way your brain
thinks because if you're like oh I know
I can't do it um I'm gonna have anything
I'm gonna have but if you start going
I'm confident I can do this I it's
amazing that the brain could reprogram
itself and it's starting to work for me
a little bit I've noticed it you got to
just you know I've never in the same
vein have you ever tried microdosing
everybody's been telling me that Theo
Rossi from Sons of Anarchy uh many many
people I'm going to try it I'm going to
do it yeah oh yeah there's a conference
I'm actually talking to the founder
tomorrow it's called microdosing uh it's
a conference in Florida that I think
it's a in Miami that's about to take
place and the speakers if you go I think
it's microdosing.com if you go look at
the speakers they have I mean I remember
meeting with Kevin Harrington from Shark
Tank yeah way back in the day when he
was on Shark Tank and now he's a speaker
at this conference and to see the
trajectory of some of these amazing
entrepreneurs that are now believing in
microdosing I think it's quite
fascinating do you micro dose you know I
I have but part of what I want to talk
to him about is that the the times that
I have more than anything it makes me
very sleepy and I know it's not supposed
to do that
yeah and I want to know if it's my
chemical makeup or like what some people
have said is well maybe it's what you
need and you're getting from the
medicine what you need and you need to
rest
so but I I don't know I mean I've I've
tried a few different micro dosing type
things
um but I but then I'll see my husband
will do it and he gets that feeling
where your mind is quite expanded and
and he feels calm
where's the feeling I'm getting is just
it literally puts me to sleep
so I want the Mind expansion you know
and I want the the groundedness and and
everything you're you know you're
talking about
um with the hypnotherapy because even
that like I I would love to do that
um I have a great person she's really
great and I was doubting it and I was
just in and all of a sudden I start
listening to these this 20 minutes at
night 20 minutes in the morning every
day and it becomes a habit and things
have changed a little bit for me I mean
it's still new but it's working I have
to say it's working I get frustrated
sometimes I don't want to do it
sometimes